she delivers healing messages to people
and gives them comfort knowing that
their loved ones who passed are still
with them just in a different way and
she's coming to town i spoke to the long
island medium teresa caputo
i was talking to you a little bit before
and i said i was kind of fangirling and
you said you're just not used to that
how how can you not be used to that yet
i'm still shocked when people like oh my
god i'm obsessed with your show i've
watched you for years i'm like oh my god
you know who i am
what exactly when you feel connected to
these spirits and these loved ones come
to you what do you feel what do you see
it's i i always say to people i wish i
could describe something really cool
that happens i don't even know how it
works i just once i start giving my
speech spirit starts to clear out my own
personal thoughts feelings and emotions
i start to see signs and symbols of
things that i've experienced here in the
physical world to relay messages to
someone else how i see the souls of the
departed are different i see shadows and
silhouettes but i'll feel more of like
an emotional bond like how you knew them
they then will bring me through their
departure and i will actually feel how
they passed and then they will also make
me feel the burden and guilt that you
carry connected to that departure as
well
we're so excited because you're going to
be in las vegas and you're doing that
shows over at the orleans arena what
what happens at the shows what can
people expect so what happens is i come
out i give a quick speech on how i
communicate with the souls of the
departed and then i start sensing them i
come off the stage i am still down in
the crowd spirit will guide me around
the space have me stop in the pers in
front of the person that they need to
speak to and deliver the messages i have
cameras that follow me around just like
on long island medium screen setup so no
matter where you're seated you can feel
and be a part of this amazing experience
if someone goes to the show is there
something that they can do
to try to get their loved one to come
through to you come with no expectations
come with an open heart and more
importantly mind and because the souls
that speak of the souls that can deliver
as many messages at one time so people
say it all the time after attending one
of my live shows they'll say i look i
didn't know what to expect when i went
to the show i personally didn't get read
but what i witnessed was changing and
then some will even go on to say and
then i realized there were other people
in that theater that needed to hear from
their loved ones more than i did
and i've noticed that you've gone up to
people before and you're you're just
like i've been looking for you and that
to me is incredible because you just get
that feeling like i'm supposed to
deliver a message to you right and and
it is that's exactly what it is it's
like a feeling like sometimes that'll
even happen at a live show like the
night before i might sense and feel
things and then nothing will happen and
then the next night i'll start see and
i'm like oh this is who i i've been
looking for you for days thank you for
what you do for people i know we're all
probably like please can you read from
my loved ones and you just you really
help you help so many people it's really
amazing to watch
thank you and you know i say this to
people also what i do is so much more
than just communicating with people that
have died let's face it over these past
19 months we've all lost something and
the experience offers
faith peace and hope so and i always say
if people leave my show with anything
more than that then i fear it exceeded
any expectation i ever would have had of
them
she's so nice i'm just gonna say she
seemed so genuine and cool and just so
gifted and
seeing those people's faces in the
crowds and the tears but she really it
has this healing power yeah there's
there's a oh i know a lot of people are
skeptical about things like that but
sometimes when you listen to her and the
things she picks up on these are not
leading questions it's like very
specific like how would you even know
that right there's no way you could know
that from looking at someone's facebook
page or that's just a true gift so i'm a
believer yeah it's very cool so she'll
be over at the orleans uh definitely
want to check out her show yeah
absolutely okay and